Hello world. It's Saroj. In this video,
we're going to write a script that
reads in a Dataset of movie ratings and
recommends new movies for a
user in 40 lines of python.
We are in the midst of a new renaissance
right now and the reason for it is data.
In the past two years,
we've created more data than in the
entire previous history of the human race.
Your options to learn or experience
or create are limitless on the wet.
This is awesome. Oh my
God, I'm going to throw up,
but all of this abundance
presents a problem.
The paradox of choice because
we have so many choices,
we could spend way too much
time trying to pick one.
We could end up not picking
anything at all or worse,
pick something and then get
fomo or fear of missing out.
If there was a way to have an abundance
of options and have certainty in our
decisions, that would be ideal, right?
That's how recommendation systems help us.
They use machine learning to
go over all of our options,
learn what we like and recommend which
option we would like best and they're
getting insanely accurate like they
know us better than we know ourselves.
Sometimes Amazon recommends products we'd
like. Google recommends search results.
We'd like Facebook
recommends friends we'd like.
Pretty much every service does it.
Now there are two main types
of recommender systems,
collaborative systems and
content based systems.
Collaborative systems predict what you
like based on what other similar users
have liked in the past.
Content based systems,
predictably you like based on what you've
liked in the past and some services
like Netflix combined both
approaches to be even more accurate.
So let's write our own script that
recommends movies a user would like.
We'll install our dependencies,
then write our script.
We're going to use three dependencies,
both num pi and PSI.
Pi will help us do some math and lite FM
is a library that allows us to perform
any number of popular
recommendation algorithms.
We'll start by importing num py and call
it NP. I'd have him as a big library,
so we're only going to import the
sub modules of it that we need.
We'll use the from import combination to
import specific methods from submodules
as necessary.
We'll import the fetch movie lens method
from the Datasets sub module and the
light FM class directly
from light offense,
which will later create a model for us.
Now that we've imported our dependencies,
we're going to fetch our dataset.
Let's create a variable called data to
store our data set and we use the fetch
movie lens method we imported earlier
from our light FM dependency that fetch
our dataset.
The movie Lens Dataset is a big CSV file
that contains a hundred k movie ratings
from one k users on 1700 movies.
Each user has rated as least 20 movies
on a scale of one to five so hopefully
they gave this a zero
basic.
See if I can track an IP address.
If that's movie lens method takes in
an auction parameter called Min rating.
I mean writing is a minimum rating
we want to include in our data.
We'll send it to 4.0 which means we're
only collecting the movies with a rating
of four or higher.
So this method will create an interaction
matrix from our CSV file in story in
our data variable as a dictionary.
A dictionary is a way to
store data just like a list,
except instead of just using
numbers to retrieve data,
you can use anything in our case
where your strengths are fetched.
Movie Lens Method Splits Dataset into
training and testing data and we could
retrieve each by using the train and test
strings as keys. We'll print out both.
Let's quickly see what this looks
like in terminal. When we compile it,
it'll print out both our
training and testing matrices.
We can see that our training day that
contains 10 times more items that are
testing data. We'll store our model
in a variable that we call model.
We'll initialize a lite FM class using a
single parameter called loss loss means
our loss function and it measures the
difference between our model's prediction
and the desired output.
We want to minimize it during training
so our model gets more accurate over time
and its predictions.
We can choose between several.
We'll go ahead and choose
a loss called warp,
which stands for weighted
approximate rank.
Pairwise warp helps us
create recommendations for
each user by looking at the
existing user rating,
pears and predicting rankings for each.
It uses the gradient descent algorithm
to iteratively find the weights that
improve our prediction over time.
This takes into account both
their users' past rating history,
content based and similar users ratings
collaborative. It's a hybrid system.
Now that we have our model,
we can go ahead and train.
It will use the fit method of
the model object to train it.
The fit method takes three parameters.
The data set we want to train it on
the number of epoxy we want to run the
training for and the number of threads
we want to run this on. For our data set,
we use our data dictionary we created
earlier and pointed to the training data
using the train strength.
We'll set the number of epochs or runs
for this training session to 30 and the
number of threads or parallel computations
to to now we want to generate a
recommendation from our model.
To do that,
we'll write a sample recommendation
function, which takes three parameters.
Our model,
our data analyst of User Ids.
These are users we want to
generate recommendations for.
First we'll get the number of users and
the number of items which are movies.
In our case using the shape attribute
of the data dictionary we created.
Now we can create a for loop to iterate
through every user id that we would
input and say that we want the list
of known positives for each light.
FM considers ratings that
are five positive and ratings
that are four or below
negative.
To make the problem binary much simpler,
we'll get the list of positive ratings
from our data in compressed sparse row
format. This is a suburb way
inside of our data matrix,
which will retrieve using
the indices attribute.
Next we'll generate our recommendations
and store them in the scores variable.
Using the predict method of our model.
We'll use a user id as the first
parameter and then a list of each movie.
The a range method of num py will give
us every number from zero up to the
number of items so we can predict
the score for every movie.
Then we'll sort them in
order of their score.
The Arg sort method of [inaudible] will
return the score indices in descending
order thanks to the negative sign.
Let's go ahead and print them.
First we'll print out the
user's ID percent has,
we'll convert the ID to a string.
Then we'll print the top
three known positive movies
that the user has picked by
creating a for loop ending
in the third index. Lastly,
we'll create one more loop for printing.
The top three recommended movies
that are modeled predicts,
we'll call it at the end using the model
data and Alyssa three random user ids
as the parameters.
Each user has movies that they like listed
as well as movies that our system has
recommended for them.
So to break it down,
recommendation algorithms help us make
decisions by learning our preferences.
There are two main types of
recommendation algorithms,
content based and collaborative.
And lastly,
why FM is a great library to get started
with building recommendation systems.
The winner of the coding challenge
from the last video is row Han Vermont
[inaudible] went above and beyond by
creating a web app where you can search a
topic and it'll list a bunch of tweets on
that topic with highlighted sentiments.
Bad Ass of the week,
and the runner up is our nod Delani,
well documented and well defined methods.
The challenge for this week is to modify
this code so that instead of using the
default fetch movie lens method,
you'll write a new method that fetches
and formats some other recommendation
dataset.
Train it on three different models,
compare the results and
print the best one post.
You're getting humbling in the comments
and I'll announce the winner in the next
video.
Links to everything in the description.
Please share this video and subscribe
for more programming videos. For now.
I've got to wonder why Yahoo still exists,
so thanks for watching.